thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Hot Seat the show at the
heart of seat and and even harder
questions today we have back in the hot
seat Mr Walter Hall
back for more pain am I too far if I
lean back or let's go you might tip all
over if you lean too far back okay no
because you know because I'm not so big
white guy I don't want to look smaller
you just got to bring your chest down
bring it up and talk with your voice a
little bit maybe turn the hat like
around so that you have like a baby but
if I turn a good team if I turn it
around then you know it doesn't say
Raiders in the back so let's talk with a
deeper voice like that yeah yeah yeah uh
Walter we're gonna start off
with a cold question because that's how
Steve's very favorite yeah so Bart
please take it over
the barcode question brought to you by
Aquafina
Kirk drink or the person the we don't
know yeah yeah are you familiar with the
with the phrase silly goose no I'm not
well I mean I I I've heard it like oh
yeah you know Steve he's silly goose oh
you think it's a different one now yeah
I'm sorry I think it changed over time
and now it's a sex position the way Bart
is asking it does sound like a sex
position what
uh brand or genre of product do you
think silly goose would be an ambassador
for
like as a catchphrase or as a name of
the product as as the like the Jared of
Subway you know like what would silly
goose be good for like an actual silly
example yeah like a silly goose like you
got a silly goose logo you know he's
talking about the Aflac logo but it's
way sillier okay what would be good
product or service this is a really good
question yeah there's like some brand
stuff there's like some marketing stuff
I think a cryptocurrency silly goose
that's actually pretty cool
right there good answer what what made
you go with crypto
because how it's not making me any money
right now
yeah it's light-hearted that's nice yeah
oh it hurts my heart what's the most you
ever lost on crypto
oh not that much
um probably like a couple thousand I
think what's the most you've ever lost
in any Child's Play Oh I can't get into
that but a lot though like what like
more than a couple thousand without
getting it
how much more I'll save more than a
couple thousand and less than a million
without games that's a big range without
getting into it what happened
well if I was to get into it
I may or may not say that like my timing
was horrible
[Music]
um like you bought Bitcoin at 69 000. I
know you know if you bought a huge steak
in firefest
um I actually went to another
um the when Tesla so before oh gosh
before Tesla cars were like crazy
popular the stock was like going up one
day 200. down the next day like 150 or
300 and then up the next day 200 and I
was like you know oh oh and then I
jumped in and then like it went up like
100 bucks I was like oh this is dope
dude right and then I didn't pull out
and then the next day it dropped like
300 like two three and I was like I was
like sweating like I was like oh my God
what's and then like in the over the
next two or three days it went up and I
made most of my losses back so you're
like oh thank God it was sold and then
of course after that it just kept going
up and then it split and then kept going
up again and then but then so my friends
like oh you should have pulled up no you
know what it stressed me out so much
that when it was down I had lost so much
that I I was like I didn't know what to
do how much was it when you were down
how much is loose oh I also see five
figures oh yeah that's what I figured
and then but like you know I made it
back because on the swing back up but
then I I pulled down I couldn't take the
stress of like the ups and downs like I
said of course after that it just kept
going up and this was so this was around
when it was like when I say it was like
180 150 180 200 around there wow and it
was just going up like it's like a
thousand bucks now right yeah now it's
like but this is after multiple splits
it's a thousand now but like this is 300
today oh 300 so it's contracts but it's
split though it's split like what two at
the end of um August so if it didn't
split then it would be 600 or even 1200
or something yeah split twice three for
one it split yeah wow dude so like but
this is before like this is this is this
is around the time um the meme stocks
are going crazy like Blackberry all that
and so GameStop yeah GameStop so Tesla
was going up and down like 100 and I was
just like oh and I was like literally
like you know the double dutch situation
I'm just like checking your [ __ ] every
day dude and then down I'm like do I
pull out like and then by then like
literally you blink 50 is gone and then
you bring again like another 100 I'm
like oh oh I know what I do what I do
and then like over the next couple and
like I just kind of kept I was like you
know I'm just gonna keep it in there
just because who knows what's gonna
happen and then the next couple days it
came back and then I just sold and like
I'm like I'm like even now I'm hesitant
to play with Tesla
only because of that experience but
other stocks other crypto is cool with
you just Tesla itself for the stock yeah
you know you know like for me it's like
it's like alcohol like
tequila messed you up one night in
college or high school and you're like
I'm never gonna touch it again and even
the smell of tequila gets you nauseous
that's kind of how Tesla is for me can
you drive a Tesla I can't okay that's
good it's just all shaking the
volatility he thinks he thinks the
speedometer is the [ __ ] stock if I
get my wallet in my mouth I just floor
it take to get out of the way uh but
yeah so Tesla's kind of like my like
tequila
so to speak but I may get back into it
just because you know just split
recently yeah three to one yeah so it
gets a little more affordable would you
would you buy Ram stock if they went
public I would I would I would because
it'll be really low right now hey good
answer there's a stock right now it's a
It's actually an ETF that has uh K-pop
companies so Hive which is bts's company
YG which is black pink and I think one
other one so it's an ETF that just
monitors those those because those
companies are all public
and so it's an ETF on K-POP and I was
like you know what that would have been
a cool ETF before BTS went crazy big
yeah because right now everything's kind
of leveling off but uh right now there's
no group other than BTS and blackpink
but they're not moving the meter because
they're already so high up I mean
they're they're yeah they're the number
one boy and girl group in the world
globally blackpink is the number one
subscribe to like billions of views on
uh YouTube really yeah so they passed
Justin Bieber I think earlier this year
or late last year and so they're already
up there there's no movement now all
they have is to go down that's crazy so
I'm not doing that ETF but had it been
like earlier on then I probably would
have smart are you is there something
about investing that you have advice for
maybe people who are watching like that
you would look out for start with what
you're okay losing so if it's 50 bucks
just do 50 bucks if it's a thousand
dollars go through a thousand dollars
but you got to be okay losing it going
in going with the Battalion that I'm
gonna lose this
so that anything that happens you're
okay with it you can weather that storm
because if you put in a hundred bucks
and let's say it drops 20 bucks you're
gonna be you're gonna drive yourself
crazy yeah I couldn't lose that hundred
I needed that for whatever don't do it
don't do it don't don't put in 100 only
put in what you're okay losing and once
you do that you just gotta literally
read so much and like take advice from
all the big people the top person you
take advice from who always gives advice
surprisingly so good
he said only put it only put in what
you're okay 10xing I'm in did you see
that guy that God that that did
everything opposite to Jim Cramer and he
made [ __ ]
he's up he's up like yeah that's the
whole Pelosi would you listen to Pelosi
you know what I should bet with Polo I
would I would not listen to her but if I
had access to what she was investing in
I would follow you do it's publicly it's
public instrument what comes late it
comes late yeah so it's like it'll pump
after buying High dude all the
politicians in the proper committees
I I would I would follow that oh yeah
but like honestly like if you're
starting out just listen follow Warren
Buffett he's very generous with his
information and he's and his strategy is
is long term it's always long term
um I've dabbled in day trading that
doesn't mean I'm any good at it I
dabbled in it but if you're if you get
stressed out easily that's super
stressful emotional bro it's a lot of
philanomics going on like meaning like
it's just unfeeling because you're like
I'm sure of a lot the day Traders
they're researching day and night and so
they're not doing philanomics but for me
who's not researching day and night it's
all phelanomics
um you just look at the graph like I
think it's gonna go that way even the
technical analysis is basically
philanomics but it's the idea that we're
tracking it in some sense right you can
like quantify it in some way so that
everybody in the market is sort of
following the same-ish trends because
they use the same rules so it's kind of
a fascinating thing but it scares the
[ __ ] out of me it's like creating a
baseline because everyone does tea yeah
so it's like how price targets work
where people have this number in their
head and everyone else shares it and
almost goes viral in a way and so once
it goes to say a certain price people go
no the ceiling's higher because
everyone's been talking about going off
to here yeah it's like anchoring in a
negotiation like you start the number so
now everyone's thinking about the number
fascinating yeah well um it is the 9
Minute 52 second Mark where we like to
turn up the heat okay um so we would
like to ask if you if there's a moment
in your life where you thought about
giving up on your dreams
first off do you have dreams
I feel like I don't know which question
to answer first because
it's like do you have dreams and then
did you ever go back did you ever feel
like
giving up on them as I've gotten older
my dreams have changed okay I don't say
change because that's too strong a word
they've altered okay so like when I was
younger it was like you know be rich and
famous you know be recognized everywhere
as I've gotten older it's now just like
hey if I could perform stand-up every so
often at a club and maybe we'll laugh
I'm good I'm happy you know I'm like
that satisfies me like I don't need uh
Fame and wealth that'd be great don't
get me wrong if the tenant to me I'm
gonna take it you don't want to get a
model so far so you can't even walk
around so far I don't want that actually
yeah but you wanted that before I wanted
that before now it's like it'd be cool
if like you know someone goes hey you're
Walter right yeah that's that's enough
[ __ ] you man yeah
it's like you know I'm eating nachos my
fingers all cheese can I take a photo uh
like can you hold up real quick man you
suck I know I know you know um I spent I
spent thirty dollars on a stock you
[ __ ] suck dude I couldn't afford to
lose it actually
it was all on Tesla I've heard that
actually a lot and I actually feel that
too like it's like when we're young we
wanna achieve those things but then and
and coming from people who's achieved
that in like a crazy sense like I've
heard the same thing as like when you
get older you don't give a [ __ ] you want
to be invisible but isn't it cute you
weren't here earlier but we had a young
man who was sitting in your chair and
and we were asking him about Fame and he
was like he's like I'm scared of it
because I don't wanna I don't want
chicks to [ __ ] me to death basically
that's be that's your age bro I'm sorry
that's your age is he like afraid of
like too much too much [ __ ] [ __ ] me
today he's like what he's like he's like
he's like looking he's like Googling
like if I come too much like will I die
and it's like yeah you could hydrate
like if I come too much yeah so he's
like thinking about that and like he's
got a guitar and he's like singing a
song and well I get my ball sack way too
drained and bruised by the groupies yeah
okay can a woman suck your penis
completely off of your body is he the
urban legend guy that turns down women
like I've heard he's that's what he said
I've heard about these mythical
creatures turn them down to turn them on
oh yeah like this girl wanted me but I
turned her down because she's a fan like
in what world it's too hot yeah too hot
yeah so what were your dreams how were
they altered and okay yeah so am I doing
yeah Fame Fortune
um to be recognized to like walk into a
comedy club Walter's here yeah go up on
stage man any time like that that's to
me that's a cool dream but um as I've
gotten older it's alter a little bit
like I don't care too much about Fame
and Fortune
um it's just now to be content like with
whatever little I'm doing because I feel
like if I'm content with whatever little
I'm doing when i'm doing more I'm that
much more content
um and hopefully my my happiness isn't
based on like what I'm doing or not
doing hopefully yeah
um but yeah like I I think um now I look
at like okay I should start writing more
just so I don't need to be like on stage
or whatever uh like writing scripts or
if it ever comes to that
um but yeah definitely for sure like
with that guy like you know talking
about getting laid too much that urban
legend
um like for me dude like honestly I I'm
lucky if like a woman says hi to me like
after a show like I feel like oh dude
like
she said hi this is amazing and I'll go
home feeling happy about that you know
forget about like hey Walter like I want
to suck your [ __ ] like you know take me
back to your place like forget about
that like and guaranteed if that happens
to me I'm not gonna turn that down
how do you do that I don't understand
like you know I get it if you have 10 of
them after you and you send like two
away when I get that or you get 10 after
you because you already had 10 and
you're so drained yeah and you're just
like no ladies you never know a chance
which guy is going to say that at the
end you have no idea yeah yeah you don't
know but you know it's a curveball I was
in a position like that though I
sacrifice my body
this is you're about charity yeah
because this for me this is the main
reason is because if those women were
non-asian
I feel as though I need to step up for
my fellow asian brothers we gotta
represent brother represent because I
don't want them to lose an opportunity
with a white woman you gotta lay down
the hammer exactly because if a white
woman wants me and then I don't lay it
down Asians suck because it's never it's
never walks yourself
but if I lay it down okay it's not like
Walter was amazing it was like Asian
guys yeah you boost everything so you
want to lead into a good stereotype so
you're contributing for that would you
ever be down to to Bone a white chick
and then pull your penis out on the
order well that one of her Asian friends
suck on your penis within what white
[ __ ] tastes like yeah
he has to think about it because that's
that's brotherly love that's really
Brotherly Love Asian friends they must
be so curious yeah they're like what is
it like Walter I want to know what white
[ __ ] tastes like let me suck your dick
yeah okay so when you said Asian friend
it could be man or man or female yeah in
my mind it was a female yeah right but
then I see now that maybe you're
probably asking like let's say you
you're like hey well he wants something
yeah I don't know why [ __ ] tastes like
I need to suck your dick what I would do
in that case it tastes a lot more like
dick
it's not awkward for either of us it's
not like no I'm saying so I would make
it so it's not awkward because I would
probably take my finger and then and
then rub it and then let you lick my
finger oh no
and then I give you my right finger so
that you would know oh I see notes of
his finger and I will taste notes that's
too much math too much man don't taste
your white finger don't taste the
[ __ ] same that's the problem there's
no Baseline necessary that's too much
math fingers taste no no you need a
palette cleanser but I was saying for
for Bart's sake he'll be like oh it
tastes dip like I don't know but this is
other flavor oh that's Walter's finger I
want him to be I tell you what I want to
do okay okay what do you want to do get
whatever the White Chicks you're boning
you get her perfume you spray it on the
top of your penis that way when I go all
the way in okay I put your favorite
penis all the way down my throat I could
smell what she smells like I don't think
you could I don't think they'd have to
be down your throat question that's
weird question what makes you think you
could take it all in that's what I'm
saying I'll try I don't think you could
Bart's got a pretty big mouth though
how's that throat open up oh
doesn't work his mouth out today look at
this jawline dude look at that do you
have that rope mechanism thing oh you
put in your mat and you do jaw lifts I
don't think he has tonsils
you gotta remove when he's very young
but that's that's a good question though
like that honestly that's a good
question like if like your friend like
let's because the assumption is is that
while I'm boning a white girl which is
which was like a unicorn experience Bart
would be there watching what about other
races does it have to be white what
about oh no this is Bart scenario so I
just feel like it no jerseys are you bro
no but like that you know if you guys
want to know what white [ __ ] tastes
like I think I look like I know
[Laughter]
we already know what your mom tastes
like I think he was asking just a
register it's my sister sorry sorry
is this not patreon you gotta get up on
it you look like you know what oil
baroness [ __ ] tastes like oil baroness
I look like I go to the Middle East and
get railed by a Saudi Prince yeah
but you play a [ __ ] mean hand of
Poker though you know you look like that
Raiders fan yeah you know oh he's
wearing greater
what is your
deepest darkest fear deepest darkest
fear yeah white [ __ ] probably yeah no
actually it's not just it's a Bart being
there
hey hey can I get a taste Walter
oh come on I'm heterosexual
there's that this is old like uh uh like
I think it was a Penthouse Letters
cartoon where um total racist cartoon
but I think it applies there's a white
girl like sleeping with a yellow dude
and then like in the next thing the
white dude I mean the yellow dude's done
and he like gets off of her and she's
still like I think she's blindfolded or
whatever oh no she had blindfolded she's
just laying there and then he's like oh
it was so good and then he drops down
and then another Asian guy comes out
from underneath the bed and he keeps
boning her and so she thinks it's the
same guy this is a comic strip he has a
comic strip he doesn't you know because
to white people Asians look the same and
so there's like three Asian guys
underneath the bed and that to me that's
what reminded me when Bart said like I'm
gonna be in the room and it kind of
tastes what it tastes like I'm gonna do
you could do it yourself she won't know
the difference dude good joke yeah
are you sure that wasn't an Abercrombie
shirt I know
got that mixed up
what an article not that I read
Penthouse so is that your deepest
Mountain here
he's like I'm that guy yeah the darkest
fear is that you know all of us will be
there and it'll be Stephen on the bed
we'll just be switching off we'll just
be switching off uh my deepest darkest
fear is probably like loneliness
um
um like I'm an only child and so like
you know my parents are old when they
pass like there won't be if I don't get
married there won't be any family yeah
so like loneliness is probably the
deepest darkest oh wow no cousins no
cousins and stuff but it's not like we
hang out oh are they pretty lame
you seem like you have a tight friend
group though I do I do but it's still a
little bit it's still a little different
than family of course you know that's a
little different
um and then like other than that like
you know walking down an alley and you
know someone tries to mug me that's
scary like yo I I don't don't hurt me
I'll give you my money and they're like
I'm not after money yeah and you're like
[ __ ] terrified that's like season
three of The Shield I was like oh my God
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah you guys
watch that [ __ ] yeah wow this this milk
well it's a who cares as well but this
this like guy copies like the chief of
police we've been following him for
three seasons
during like a house called Robin
no no no um this other guy is this
Mexican dude doing the show but he's
great on the show and like we love his
character and [ __ ] he's kind of a
[ __ ] dick too but but like but you
still love them and then like the whole
show like his character archive I'm not
kidding his character I got this and his
wife is and his wife is like [ __ ]
weirded out by it and [ __ ] that's crazy
[ __ ] okay dude [ __ ] TV show that was
on FX dude wow and they demonetized my
channel they [ __ ] read ads against
that [ __ ] [ __ ] year because this one
teaches a lesson doesn't it God damn it
which is yeah that's the things like you
know do you ever like get that fear like
you're walking down the street and then
next thing you know you wake up
oh yeah oh that'd be scary that sucks
and he knew they woke up and their their
mouth was sewed on someone's butthole
and then someone else's mouth was was
sewed on their butthole how come this
was a national news
I think it was called like centipede or
something centipede yeah
[Music]